need to work with these fractions is to
get rid of the fractions or eliminate
them and the way you do that is by
clearing the denominator and so what you
would do is you would look at all the
denominators of the fractions and you
say what's the common denominator or the
lowest common multiple so like if you
were getting a common denominator what
would that common denominator be another
way to say that is what's the smallest
number that 3 goes into 2 goes into and
6 goes into evenly without a remainder
so you can see they all go into 6 evenly
and that's the smallest number that
they'll all divide into evenly so what
we're going to do is we're going to
multiply this entire equation by 6 so
when you multiply by 6 you're
multiplying everything in the equation
by 6 each of the terms okay when you
multiply by 6 it's like multiplying by 6
over 1 okay because anything divided by
1 is itself so you can always write a
whole number as a fresh by putting it
over 1 and then what you'll notice here
is you can do a couple things you can
say 6 times 2 is 12 divided by 3 is 4
acts or you can cross reduce you could
say 3 goes in here once 3 goes in here
twice 2 times 2 is 4
1 times 1 is 1 4 divided by 1 is 4
either way you don't have a denominator
anymore which is which is a nice thing
right over here same thing 6 divided by
2 is 3 3 times 1 is 3 so we just get 3
and then over here you can see the 6 is
canceled so we just end up with 5 so
we've cleared the denominators now it's
a lot easier to solve this equation
we're just going to subtract 3 from both
sides
and then we're gonna divide both sides
by 4 because we just want to get X by
itself and we get 1/2 okay let's go to
the next one so number 2 here what you
can see is we have this whole quantity X
plus 10 being multiplied by 3/5 so one
way to get rid of the 3/5 is to multiply
by the reciprocal okay this is called
the multiplicative inverse and instead
of like dividing by 3/5 and dividing is
really like multiplying by the
reciprocal and by doing this you can see
that the 5s are gonna cancel and the
threes are gonna cancel and you're just
gonna be left with 1 1 times anything is
itself so now we just we just have X
plus 10 by itself right but remember
whatever you do to the left side you
have to also do that to the right side
so again you can see 3 goes into 18 six
times
six times five is thirty over one which
is thirty so now we've eliminated the
fractions which is a good thing and we
can subtract 10 from both sides and get
X by itself so you can see x equals 20
now another way to approach this problem
let's just write it down here again we
have 3/5 X plus 10 equals 18 another way
to approach this problem is again any
whole number can be thought of as a
fraction by putting it over 1 and so
what we're going to do is we're just
going to distribute the 3/5 okay into
the parenthesis so 3/5 times X and 3/5
times 10 so this gives us 3/5 X here we
get 30 fifths which is 6 right because
30 divided by 5 is 6 equals 18 so I just
multiply the numerators and the
denominators that's a good way to work
with fractions when you're multiplying
and then now we're just going to get the
variable by itself by subtracting 6 from
both sides so we get 12 and we have 3/5
X okay now at this point we're kind of
in the same position we were here
originally we want to get rid of that
3/5 we just want X we could divide both
sides by 3/5 since that's the opposite
of multiplying by 3/5 or we could use a
multiplicative inverse which works out
to be a little bit easier I think for
most students you just multiply by the
reciprocal that way these cancel and
these cancel and you get 2 X by itself
and you can see here this is 60 divided
by 3 which is 20 or you can do the cross
reducing technique 3 goes in here once 3
goes in here 4 times 4 times 5 is 20
over 1 and so you've got x equals 20 so
either way you're gonna get the same
result
so a couple examples in this video to
show you how to work with fractions
easier and more effectively so I hope
that helps you to understand it better
subscribe to the channel check out some
of my other videos on Mario's math tutor
and YouTube channel and I look forward
to seeing the future videos I'll talk to
you soon